dare to take a break from the stunning revelations
from yesterday's impeachment hearing because
we have yet another important shocking but
not altogether surprising [inaudible]
in data point in the possible cognitive decline
being experienced by the president and you
know, every week it seems more and more clear
that something is very, very wrong.
Early last week I told you about this book
called a warning, which is written by a senior
Trump staffer and many of you speculated that
the staffer might be Kellyanne Conway.
We don't know.
I don't have any news about that as far as
it goes, but we heard through a Washington
post preview last week about some of the concerning
as concerning cognitive decline related allegations
that were being made about Donald Trump regularly
slurring and stub stumbling around at the
white house and other allegations.
We now have more detail out of the book and
it is even worse than we imagined or have
been told up until now.
So to catch you up, we already knew that this
book, a warning says quote, he stumbles, slurs
gets confused, is easily irritated and has
trouble synthesizing information.
Not occasionally but with regularity.
But another element to this is Donald Trump's
memory.
And these allegations actually mirror some
public facing events that we saw.
I'll explain what I mean.
Uh, staffers who deal with Trump regularly
are saying that they noticed that the president
quote also can't remember what he's said or
been told.
Americans are used to him denying words that
have come out of his mouth according to this
senior official.
Sometimes this is to avoid responsibility,
but it often appears Trump genuinely doesn't
remember important facts.
So when we see Trump lie in public, we assume
it is merely a deliberate lie.
This book, a portion at least suggests that
Trump might genuinely not remember saying
the things that he says and then denies.
Now, I do have a word of caution here because
on the one hand, this would explain a lot.
But on the other hand, I'm hearing from more
and more of you who believe that the unplanned
hospital visit the stuff about cognitive decline
in this book, that it may all be building
a setup for Trump to gracefully exit the presidency,
avoid losing reelection, avoid impeachment.
So the idea is start a pretext of some kind
of cognitive or physical decline, which would
allow Trump to simply not run for reelection
and maybe better position Mike Pence, uh,
for the presidency in 2020.
I have no idea truly what's going on other
than the obvious, which is something is very
much wrong with the man.
There's an example which you might remember,
remember this, there was a time a few months
ago where we had a hurricane.
Hurricane was headed our way.
It was a category five hurricane.
And I reported to you at the time that Donald
Trump said this really bizarre thing.
He hasn't even heard of a category five hurricane
who's even heard of that.
That's crazy.
And we thought it was weird because it's not
just that most adults have heard of category
five hurricanes.
Trump as president presided over numerous
category five hurricanes.
The author of a warning argues that Trump
genuinely had no recollection of that.
He had no memory of the multiple category
five hurricanes during his presidency and
when he was told this is a category five hurricane
a few months ago, it sounded new to him.
That is not good.
Okay.
If that is the explanation, something is very,
very wrong and you know, we started to see
strange things before the election.
Clearly it's gotten worse and worse since,
and these things can ramp up pretty quickly.
It's not funny.
It's not sad, but it poses a national security
threat.
And of course if there is a cover up of this
going on, that is also extraordinarily problematic
and disturbing.
More and more.
The question is, if the decline continues,
how will Trump be doing by the time of the
debates with the eventual democratic presidential
nominee, will he hold it together?
Will it be evident that something is very
wrong on a national stage?
Will they try to limit the duration or number
of the debates?
We don't know yet.
We don't know the trajectory.
We don't know the specifics of what's going
on, but people around Donald Trump are noticing,
we're hearing this from a whole bunch of different
sources and at this point it's difficult to
deny that something is going on and you know,
the, it's not, any of this stuff is not anything
to make fun of.
If it's a drug problem, that's an illness,
that's not something to make fun of.
If it's cognitive decline, that's not something
to make fun of.
If there's some kind of physical health issue
that warranted that visit to the hospital,
none of this stuff is to make fun of anyone.
It's as voters, we deserve to know what is
going on.
And if there is a proactive effort made to
obfuscate, then that is something that must
be stopped immediately.
We will see what we learn in the next week,
two weeks next month, who knows?